[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID ADJAYE: Good architecture
does have this great propensity
to amplify social forces.
Technology and place and
culture are these very powerful
operating forces.
When I make public
buildings, I'm
compelled to kind of dissolve
any sense of hierarchies
which are disconcerting.
That maybe comes
from my background,
being of multiple identities.
So I'm sensitive to
how things play out.
The National Museum of African
American History and Culture
is probably the most
significant project
I've engaged in in
my career so far,
and probably will be one of the
defining projects, I'm sure.
This is a museum where the
container and the content
are one.
The museum's central
silhouette is
derived from a Yoruba
capital head, a wooden column,
which holds a porch
in a shrine house.
This triple-headed
ziggurat was actually
a beautiful way of encapsulating
this universe of ideas.
I have a deep interest in
Africa and Africa's diaspora.
When I look at abstractions
from the continents,
I'm trying to understand how
abstraction was incredibly
successful in unifying
complex tribes and groups
to create ideas about larger
collective organizations.
Culture is intrinsically
connected to fabric-- society
being a woven textile, a
system that's interconnected
and that the strength
of the society
is through that
interconnectedness.
And I'm much more interested
in thinking about architecture
through this notion of fabric,
through interconnectedness,
and through handing
down of abstractions
and interconnections.
The Sugar Hill project,
where the rose embossing
was not literally drawn.
It was a vector drawing,
which disappeared and appeared
depending on the way that
the sunlight operated on it.
And the reason for it
was because the land
that we were occupying
was farmland.
There were rose farms up there.
Buildings can imbue within
them narratives about geography
or about people, without
being mimetic or figurative.
It can use narrative to describe
what that abstraction could
be about.
Public architecture
dissolves and becomes
less about form and becomes
more about scalelessness
and interaction.
And private architecture
increasingly
becomes about
havens and moments.
So maybe from that,
you can imagine
what my ideal campus might be.
I think that the campus has
a very interesting question.
I think it asks the campus
to absolutely weld itself
with the public life
of the community.
The MIT campus is interesting.
That original building is
really powerful for students.
The architecture of that
building and its history
and its layering
of other people who
have been inspired
within that environment.
Architecture can
dissolve itself by
dismantling certain formal,
commercial, and civic ideas,
which have to do sealed
palaces of information,
to becoming more like markets.
The notion of a
place of exchange
becomes maybe a very
interesting model
for a place of
education and learning.
It's not so much about
the quantity of the books
anymore, because
actually that could
be gotten through the internet.
But the quality of the space
as a gathering, edifying space
is actually now very critical.
Because as creatures
of habit and pattern,
we actually like the idea
of places of simulation.
I think in our century,
in the 21st century,
architecture is about having the
tools which give you the data,
but constantly reapplying the
tools in very precise ways
which creates new conditions
which amplify and help society.
[MUSIC PLAYING]